[Applauso]
buon pomeriggio a tutti un attimo di
sostanze sono molto contenta di essere
qui e di presentarmi come un inclusiva
digitale e oggi volevo parlare di questo
di questo concetto che non è un concetto
così lontano da quello che ormai tanti
di noi siamo delle persone che
comunicano attraverso gli strumenti
digitali ogni giorno attraverso i vari
media whatsapp facebook e instagram e
tutti quelli che sono i media digitali
siamo diventati i protagonisti
una volta c'erano altri media che ci
rendevano in qualche modo spettatori
oggi in verità fungiamo questi ruoli
importanti di spettatori ma anche attori
è un grande cambiamento è una grande
opportunità
però c'è un problema che a volte non
siamo così inclusivi a volte utilizziamo
un media che è neutro per definizione in
un modo che non aiuta sicuramente a
poter diffondere quelli che sono dei
valori ea cercare di trovare insieme un
evoluzione progressista di questo nostro
mondo e voglio dire siamo reduci da un
periodo molto complesso dobbiamo per
forza di cose mettere insieme le nostre
forze per fare uno step evolutivo perché
oggi voglio parlare di inclusivi
digitali perché non se ne può più della
violenza perché non se ne può più della
cultura della viola
perché non se ne può più di ignorare un
fenomeno uno dei tanti fenomeni enormi
che oggi si stanno creando e diffondendo
molto più velocemente rispetto alla
volta il cyberbullismo e oggi voglio
parlare di cyberbullismo
ma prima di entrare in questo argomento
vorrei con voi leggere quello che per me
è il concetto di inclusivi digitale mi
piacerebbe che tutti noi riflettessimo
su questo prima di esprimere una
qualsiasi opinione se pur giusta quando
siamo in rete gli inclusivi digitali
siamo noi che ogni giorno ci avvaliamo
della comunicazione digitale con time to
market 0 siamo immediatamente online per
combattere la discriminazione per
diffondere le problematiche del pianeta
proponendo soluzioni per mettere a
frutto la nostra esperienza e darla con
gratuita agli altri gli inclusivi
digitali non si limitano a essere tali
solo in versione digitale ma lo sono
anche in versione analogica non è che
quando poi usciamo dal buonismo dei
social poi offline non lo siamo
gli inclusivi digitali hanno a cuore il
futuro delle nuove generazioni tutelando
le opere o provano a prevenire i
fenomeni negativi della rete gli
inclusivi digitali non criticano non
polemizzano ma non si nascondono e
trovano sempre il modo per dire la loro
in modo rispettoso gli inclusivi
digitali si educano ai nuovi strumenti
di comunicazione e non li demonizzano ma
li comprendono gli usano al meglio
maya offendendo gli altri e ora vi
racconto la mia esperienza di inclusiva
digitale con un progetto che nasce
appunto con la collaborazione di non
solo mia ma di tante persone che hanno
contribuito che si chiama bullismo che
in qualche modo è una modalità per dire
che chi bulla perde che il bullismo
cosa ma il bullismo è una brutta cosa ma
non appartiene solo alle nuove
generazioni a quel target chiamiamolo di
ragazzi di young il bullismo è un
problema della scuola è un problema
degli insegnanti ma soprattutto ha un
problema dei genitori
e se i genitori non si rendono conto che
questo problema può essere affrontato
attraverso una collaborazione diventa
indubbiamente un qualcosa che non ci
aiuterà sicuramente ad avere un futuro
milione anche perché cosa sta succedendo
che attraverso la digitalizzazione della
scuola
i fenomeni di cyber bullismo sono
esplosi il look dow ha visto
l'esplosione del cyberbullismo e quindi
noi non abbiamo delle grandi ricette
perché la grande ricetta è sempre solo
una la consapevolezza e la formazione
due parole che non sono estranee quando
parliamo appunto di saper buonismo ma
sono un po alla base di quello che è
stato il nostro progetto
quindi un progetto che abbiamo
affrontato a livello scolastico
attraverso un supporto con una
piattaforma appunto digitale la
cosiddetta fa della formazione a
distanza che noi in qualche modo quattro
anni fa abbiamo lanciato per fare in
modo che gli insegnanti potessero fare
un percorso un percorso strutturato
ovviamente con l'aiuto di psicologi
magistrati quindi persone che ovviamente
sanno affrontare in un modo scientifico
il tema del bullismo formazione e
sensibilizzazione degli insegnanti
poi però quando si poteva ancora andare
nelle scuole
siamo entrati e attraverso diciamo così
l'uso di queste assemblee abbiamo
parlato i ragazzi ma ne abbiamo anche
ascoltati e poi vedremo cosa è successo
il supporto ai genitori abbiamo creato
questo decalogo molto semplice molto
short che ci ha permesso proprio di dire
genitori quelli che sono le regole
minime per capire se in casa hanno un
bullo o un bulli dato perché poi alla
fine sono le facce di una stessa
medaglia di un disagio che è presente
e ancora è qui per me nasce la
definizione proprio di inclusivo
digitale la generazione che nasce nativa
digitale che è quindi questi giovani
ragazzi quelli che chiamo perché gli
beer i pari i giovani ragazzi che loro
possano diventare la linfa l'energia per
poter combattere il cyber bullismo sono
loro che attraverso un messaggio di
diffusione costante fra i loro amici
possono combattere il fenomeno
perché se arriva un amico un ragazzo è
finalmente insieme a tanti altri ragazzi
viene definito che il bullismo una
brutta cosa vi garantisco che si
innescherebbe un meccanismo totalmente
differente e abbiamo creato questo
progetto ho alcune foto
ripeto quando si poteva creare una
fermamente nelle scuole ma la cosa bella
è stato ascoltarli è stato fare
brainstorming è stato capire e sentire
le loro idee perché poi alla fine le
soluzioni vengono spesso da chi il
problema lo affronta ma non ha il
coraggio di parlarne con gli insegnanti
e ne con i genitori
e ancora abbiamo coinvolto degli
inclusivi digitali chiamiamole così
persone anche nel mondo dello spettacolo
del mondo della scienza che ci hanno
dato una mano a diventare in qualche
modo degli ambassador per andare
raccontare ea parlare di quello che era
appunto il problema il fenomeno ma
soprattutto è stato durante momenti
partecipativi in cui abbiamo chiesto a
chi aveva subito fenomeni di bullismo di
raccontarlo ma anche a chi era bullo di
raccontare perché era tale e quindi il
confronto è ancora qui ripeto tanti
personaggi che ci hanno veramente
aiutato in questo percorso
e poi cosa è successo che siamo arrivati
a questa consapevolezza piena attraverso
gli incontri con i ragazzi attraverso
l'ascolto attraverso sessioni proprio di
condivisione con loro che il ruolo
cruciale doveva essere proprio la loro
partecipazione attiva e allora siamo
iniziati appunto abbiamo diciamo siamo
partiti da questo progetto su milano
perché diciamo così abbiamo voluto
iniziare da lì abbiamo trovato una serie
di collaborazioni e siamo andati in giro
per le scuole oltre che per fare
formazione anche per
capire di formare un gruppo di ragazzi
prima piccolo poi sempre più grande che
potessero diventare quelli che abbiamo
chiamato peer ambassador in qualche modo
gli ambasciatori che possano poi
diventare i famosi personaggi e
protagonisti di questa diciamo così
viralizzazione al positivo questo
concetto del peer to peer e quindi
questi ragazzi che in qualche modo sono
dei rappresentanti di classe e hanno
proprio il ruolo l'obiettivo di capire
meglio di come possono essere a volte
appunto i genitori ed insegnati se c'è
un ruolo ma sanno anche perfettamente
che sono quelli che poi se vedono che
c'è un problema strutturale devono poi
far ricorso ovviamente a degli adulti ma
l'idea è usarli perché perché loro hanno
anche la grande capacità di parlare
attraverso i social a parlare attraverso
il web
parla attraverso tutta una forma di
comunicazione che spesso noi adulti
genitori insegnanti
agi ignoriamo e quindi dobbiamo
necessariamente ricorrere a questi
ragazzi e quindi è nato questo comitato
devo dire stato è detta però il primo
comitato nazionale che è stato proprio
creato da peer ambassador quindi da
questi ragazzi che sono di età compresa
fra i 12 e 15 anni e che hanno avuto
subito un compito è il compito è stato
quello proprio di scrivere un documento
documento devo dire molto corposo che è
nato da tutta una serie di sessioni di
lavoro con l'aiuto ovviamente di
insegnanti di psicologi di magistrati
perché una cosa che forse molti
dimenticano e che il bullismo è un reato
e quando si entrava nelle classi e
sincere ragazzi ma vuoi sapere che
bullismo un reato devo dire che loro
rimaniamo sorpresi perché non si rendono
conto di dove il limite di uno scherzo
che ci sta fra compagni e quando diventa
un fenomeno di bullismo e questo tipo di
discorso quindi ha portato a questo
lavoro che è un lavoro proprio di un
manuale molto secondo me chiaro facile
ma soprattutto scritto dai ragazzi per i
ragazzi
ed è per questo che oggi vi parlo degli
inclusivi digitali perché gli inclusivi
digitali non sono altro che quelle
persone che non devono per forza di cose
essere necessariamente persone con
culture incredibili o di esperienze
pazzesche ma persone che cercano in modo
sano di diffondere i valori positivi
oggi qui vi ho parlato di questo
progetto molto velocemente che cerca di
affrontare in modo positivo e di
combattere in modo positivo motivante
quello che è il fenomeno sempre più
crescente di un cyber bullismo ma
ovviamente port che porta delle
conseguenze drammatiche sapete che
purtroppo ci sono delle statistiche che
parlano proprio di numeri che sono
devastanti di ragazzi 10 per cento dei
ragazzi che pensano di tentare il
suicidio se sono appunto puliza t
ma queste cose a volte li ignoriamo
migliorano anche purtroppo i genitori
per cui quello che mi piace oggi parlare
che l'inclusione digitale è quella
persona che però mette in evidenza in
modo sano anche i problemi ambientali i
problemi di violenza sulle donne
i problemi di violenza in assoluto che
questo mondo sta affrontando e ma
ricordiamoci sempre con modi che sono
modi gentili educati perché la
polarizzazione che si è vero che la
polarizzazione e spesso porta a indici
di visualizzazione molto alti ma spesso
è una mera strumentalizzazione e pepe e
spero finalmente che l'uso del digitale
che è una grande rivoluzione perché ci
permette di parlare con persone che sono
all'altro
venga fatto in modo sano e non solo
strumentale come a volte e troppe volte
vedo fare
e tutto ciò non mi piace e credo che non
deve piacere a tutti e credo che non
deve piacere soprattutto in un momento
storico come questo dove c'è stata
un'accelerazione drammatica e lo sapete
benissimo con della digitalizzazione
quindi io oggi a maggior ragione sono a
parlare di questo discorso a fare questo
discorso perché il lock down ha portato
come potete immaginare come avete
distrutto tutti un'incredibile impennata
del fenomeno digitale karin eludibile e
lo sappiamo però dobbiamo anche cercare
di essere preparati perché sappiate bene
di quanto male può fare un insulto una
polemica a delle persone cioè io direi
che appunto cioè di haters ne abbiamo
abbastanza
e volevo concludere con vediamo se ho
fatto un click
vediamo se devo fare un altro eccolo qua
lo immagino che lo riconoscete c'è stata
questa iniziativa molto bella di
disegnare un murales nella città in cui
willy purtroppo è stato ucciso perché
questo è il termine e c'è stata questa
veglia che è stata fatta durante la
notte è un po questo speech lo dedico a
lui ma non perchè perchè lui è vittima
di una cultura di violenza che sempre di
più è presente nel mondo sono
preoccupato per un mondo migliore
sono preoccupato per la giustizia
sono preoccupato per la fratellanza sono
preoccupato per la libertà e quando si è
preoccupati di queste cose non si può
predicare la violenza perché attraverso
la violenza
puoi uccidere un assassino ma non puoi
uccidere l'omicidio con la violenza
puoi uccidere un bugiardo ma non puoi
stabilire la verità con la violenza puoi
uccidere una persona che odia
ma non puoi uccidere l'odio attraverso
la violenza
l'oscurità non può cancellare l'oscurità
sono la luce può farlo queste sono
parole di martin luther king buona luce
a tutti grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]